now welcome to this video a five minute
game against shimmy from the UK simon
and soul okay so on Queens gambit so a
sloth and playing with queen bee three
all of them slightly offbeat lines that
white can try it's a fairly solid one
that I can really recommend that plated
the number of times on video already
normally getting quite quite promising
positions white he has a slight edge in
the center with an additional center
porn D for you three against just the
six on six born and term it's very nice
to to have the long diagonal bishop eng
two and now black is does this kind of a
flawed 94 mmm are fairly typical but
there is a problem I don't have
something on d2 or C 3 that black can't
exchange the night against so the
sometimes can be an issue that the night
is basically you are not not doing that
much yep okay I'm trying to to use this
fact in going for f3 and you for maybe
the night on e 1 can be used on d3 later
ok so I'm going to going to play
whatever just mentioned grabbing this
the center you form mmm yeah why not
there is no reason not to
maybe could have taken on the form now
that I think of it but okay it didn't
happen okay i will just queen have to
probably okay yeah I don't mind trades
here I have this additional part in the
center the e4 pawn controlling important
squares so one gap young rookie tix
stereotactic no I don't think so some
sort of discovery of the rook I don't
think so i can just play rugby one next
this looks like a fairly comfortable
position
yeah just get this the defoliant if i
take here I'm taking you five as well so
yeah not directly but the list you
cannot take on be to this is what I was
getting at the trade would be quite okay
for me I still have this extra porn in
the send and my got the D file
I don't really want to take on v60 that
that's not something that helps me very
much really would like to have him trade
on deform are interesting mmm not quite
sure where he wants to go i mean i can
just a ticket 93 route d2 is no problem
yeah well the bishop wasn't such a great
piece I don't don't mind that too much
the night can be used effectively on the
e 30 at four so it's activated this way
okay it seems that he wants to get this
straight in okay check yeah and in
general it is certain okay to have the
bishop with um with this type of
non-symmetrical confirmation but the
important point here is that I have this
huge advantage in space and King
activity and will be for in the coming
e5 I'm preventing this pawn majority
from from going anywhere so I don't
think that that black has any any edge
here the question is do does ooh I have
an advantage yeah maybe yes but not
quite sure how much it is blacks
position still seems fairly solid yeah
okay I don't want to take here on f6
after pawn takes he's got King d6 and c5
coming this is what I want to prevent
not quite sure how to improve from the
night position here is a four a five
something to consider and then maybe
night to a form not not clear not not
sure about the night position here
hmm tough see forever maybe I go for if
way from a lot i'm not sure really yeah
i might be able to take and place c5
that's a bit of a problem okay well
that's not ideal but I didn't didn't see
anything better really King d6 mmm yeah
yeah at the bishop is Sir beginning to
to prove that it's a better piece hmm
not quite sure how to defend that it's
not a very very convenient position to
play check yeah probably have to do that
at some point
time morning yoga can go here I skepta
Bishop here
yeah i can go Bishop t1 until he saw
that ok yung-chun claw offered here i'm
probably it is a draw but i'd like to
check i can go to d5 for that city
really my idea i mean was so silly DRA
love it if you will I gain drawn yeah it
deserves just just totally equal um yeah
around here I felt I should have some
advantage in descending but it didn't
really materialize maybe is a form roof
was a bad idea AI it was a bad idea I
can I can play e5 first that's in fact
much better yeah this is a bit more
interesting because of my space
advantage being more important with more
pieces on the board this is what I
should have done really ok yeah after
yes it's probably it's probably just not
much happening I mean like like got
something probably yeah I should have
defended better but there is no I don't
think that there is a serious problem
here i get i get so many bones exchanged
that there is a probably just equality
mmm yeah why did I did I screw up here I
mean screw up is a bit of a strong word
but I thought I thought I should should
keep some slight edge at least and it
didn't happen yeah maybe just this a 5
news that that I should have done a bit
later to have more in the end game
alright thanks for watching